Pour mieux apprendre et réussir plus
facilement en classe, c’est simple,
voici le secret : il faut surligner son cours,
le plus possible, le relire des dizaines de fois,
et puis faire des fiches, sur lesquelles
on va réécrire complètement le cours,
mais en tout petit et très
serré, avec des abréviations.
Alors non, en fait pas du tout, si vous faites ça
: arrêtez, ça ne marche pas. Mais rassurez-vous,
je vais vous dire ce qui marche, et je vais
pas juste vous dire ce que je pense qui marche,
je vais pas essayer de vous vendre
ma méthode miracle personnelle.
Non, je vais vous parler de principes
d’apprentissage qui ont été évalués par des
centaines études scientifiques, depuis maintenant
plusieurs décennies. Des méthodes qui fonctionnent
bien mieux pour apprendre, que vous soyez au
collège, au lycée, ou dans les études supérieures.
Malheureusement, ce sont des méthodes qu’on
ne nous enseigne pas forcément à l’école,
et il existe de nombreuses idées fausses sur le
sujet. Notamment des techniques très populaires,
mais qui, en fait, n’ont pas du tout fait
leur preuves, scientifiquement parlant.
J’en ai donné des exemples :
relire son cours plein de fois,
le surligner avec plein de couleurs,
ou encore faire des fiches. Ce sont des
techniques peu efficaces, mais pas trop
fatigantes, qui vous donnent l’illusion
de maîtriser le sujet. Ça ne marche pas
bien, mais ça donne bonne conscience.
Et c’est assez incroyable de voir qu’à
côté de ça, il existe des principes
d’apprentissage et des techniques qui ont
été éprouvées par des études scientifiques,
testées dans des tas de matières, à différents
niveaux, et qui sont étonnamment peu connues.
Et j’aimerai non seulement essayer de vous
aider tous, dans vos situations d’apprentissage,
mais aussi contribuer un peu à faire tomber ce
mythe tenace qui est que la réussite scolaire est
juste une question de talent naturel, de capacité
innée à être bon dans telle ou telle matière.
Bien sûr, on est tous différents
et il y a des affinités naturelles,
mais vos capacités sont loin d’être figées, et la
façon dont vous allez vous y prendre pour étudier
à un impact énorme : vous avez beaucoup plus la
main que vous ne le pensez, sur votre réussite.
Et à nouveau pour être clair : je suis pas gourou,
j’ai pas de bouquin ou de formation
à vendre sur le sujet, je fais pas
de coaching. Je veux juste vous parler de ce que
j’ai découvert dans la littérature scientifique,
et vous faire profiter de ce que j’aurai
aimé savoir plus tôt dans mes études.
Bien, pour commencer, qu’est-ce qu’on essaye de
faire, dans le fond ? C’est quoi notre objectif
quand on essaye d’apprendre quelque chose.
Qu’est-ce que ça voudrait dire de «mieux»
apprendre ? Evidemment cela va dépendre de
la matière et du niveau où vous étudiez,
mais on retrouve quand même
toujours les mêmes éléments.
[PYRAMIDE A un premier niveau, apprendre cela veut
dire mémoriser. Mémoriser des textes, des faits,
des formules, etc. C’est vrai dans toutes les
matières et à tous les niveaux : du primaire
au supérieur, des langues aux sciences.
Il faut toujours mémoriser des choses.
Mais ça ne s’arrête pas là : on vous
demande également de comprendre,
c’est-à-dire d’acquérir une maitrise
des concepts qu’on vous présente.
Comment les différentes connaissances
factuelles s’articulent entre elles.
Mémoriser le texte d’un cours, et maitriser les
idées qu’il contient, ça n’est pas la même chose.
Vous pouvez apprendre par coeur la définition
et la formule de l’énergie cinétique, si vous ne
comprenez pas vraiment ce que ça représente, vous
n’êtes pas très avancés pour utiliser ces notions.
Ensuite à un troisième niveau, on vous
demande de «résoudre des problèmes».
J’utilise ce terme de façon assez générique, ça
peut désigner aussi bien un exercice en chimie
qu’une analyse de document en géographie, ou
la réponse à une problématique de dissertation.
Et pour résoudre des problèmes, il vous
faut une capacité à mobiliser et utiliser
les connaissances et la compréhension que
vous avez. Cette idée de pouvoir mobiliser
ce que l’on a appris, c’est quelque
chose de très important dont je vais
beaucoup reparler. C’est ce qui fait passer
progressivement du savoir, au savoir-faire.
Et enfin, parfois, on vous demande de faire preuve
de créativité. Par exemple pour imaginer une façon
de résoudre un problème formulé de façon très
ouverte, ou pour une dissertation à haut niveau.
Et ce qui est vraiment très
important ici, dans ce schéma,
c’est que ces capacités se construisent
les unes sur les autres. Chacune est
indispensable à celles qui sont au-dessus.
On pourrait penser qu’à l’heure de Wikipédia,
tout le savoir du monde est à portée de clic,
et donc on s’en fout de mémoriser des trucs.
Mais c’est faux, même tout en haut, pour les
tâches créatives, on a besoin d’avoir des
connaissances solides. La créativité, c’est très
souvent associer des choses de façon nouvelle,
et ça demande d’avoir des connaissances
qui soient disponibles et flexibles,
qu’on arrive à mobiliser dans une situation
qui ne les appelait pas forcément.]
Bref, notre objectif quand on apprend, et
qu’on veut maitriser complètement un sujet,
c’est de savoir faire tout ça : mémoriser,
comprendre, résoudre, créer. A nouveau,
la répartition va varier suivant la matière
et le niveau, mais on retrouve toujours ça.
Et vous allez voir que les méthodes qu’on
va discuter vont d’abord particulièrement
s’appuyer sur la mémorisation, car
c’est le fondement de la compréhension,
et de la capacité à créer et à résoudre des
problèmes en sachant mobiliser ce qu’on a appris.
[jingle]
Pour pouvoir vous présenter les meilleures
méthodes et vous faire comprendre leurs
justifications scientifiques, je vais utiliser
un modèle issu des sciences cognitives,
et qui permet de comprendre
comment fonctionne notre mémoire.
[MODELE Dans ce modèle, on distingue deux
formes de mémoire : la mémoire de travail
et la mémoire à long terme. La mémoire de
travail contient ce que vous avez à l’esprit,
à un instant donné. Ce dont vous
avez conscience explicitement, là,
maintenant, et sur lequel vous
pouvez tenir des raisonnements.
Cette mémoire de travail reçoit notamment les
perceptions sensorielles auxquelles on décide
de prêter attention : visuelles, auditives,
tactiles, textuelles etc. Mais elle a une
capacité très limitée : on ne peut avoir en
tête simultanément que quelques concepts.
De son côté, la mémoire à long
terme, comme son nom l’indique,
permet le stockage des connaissances et
des concepts que l’on va retenir longtemps,
au-delà du laps de temps très limité de
notre mémoire de travail. Et cette mémoire
à long terme a notamment la capacité
de se réorganiser, de se consolider.
Pour ceux qui aiment les analogies,
on peut comparer ces deux mémoires à
la RAM et au disque dur d’un ordinateur.
L’une facilement accessible qui permet de
travailler sur l’information, l’autre plus
grande, qui sert au stockage à long terme.
Entre ces deux types de mémoire, il
existe deux opérations : l’encodage,
qui permet le transfert d’informations de la
mémoire de travail vers la mémoire à long-terme.
Et la récupération qui fait l’inverse :
qui vient charger dans votre mémoire de
travail des connaissances qui avaient été
stockées dans votre mémoire à long-terme.
Et bien évidemment, ça n’est pas tout, il y a
un autre processus à l’oeuvre : l’oubli. Quand
vous retenez un numéro de téléphone juste le
temps de le taper, vous le mettez uniquement
dans votre mémoire de travail, et ensuite il
va s’évaporer rapidement, sans aller plus loin.
Mais il y a aussi de l’oubli avec la mémoire
à long-terme : des choses que vous avez sues,
mais que vous avez progressivement oubliées.]
Et pourtant des fois, on a tous
cette sensation de réapprendre ou
redécouvrir quelque chose qu’on avait
su, et de se dire : «ah oui en fait,
je m’en serai pas souvenu, mais je le
savais». Et ce qu’il se passe dans ce cas,
ça n’est pas vraiment qu’on avait oublié,
c’est qu’on arrive plus à se le rappeler.
[MEMOIRE La connaissance était peut-être toujours
là quelque part dans la mémoire à long-terme,
mais c’est la récupération qui a
échoué, qui n’a pas pu se faire.
Une façon de se représenter ce qu’il se passe,
c’est que quand vous stockez quelque
chose dans votre mémoire à long-terme,
l’information va s’y loger avec des petites
accroches, des petites poignées, qui vont
permettre la récupération. C’est ce qu’on appelle
des indices, ou des amorces de récupération.
Et bien souvent, avec la mémoire à
long terme, ce qu’on appelle «oubli»,
c’est en fait la perte progressive de ces
amorces de récupération. La connaissance est là,
mais impossible de la récupérer, de l’attraper
pour la charger dans votre mémoire de travail.
Et cette notion d’amorces de
récupération, elle est extrêmement
importante car plus il y en a qui
sont associées à une connaissance,
plus cette connaissance sera facilement
disponible, utilisable et flexible.]
Et ça c’est très important dans les tâches
cognitives comme la résolution de problèmes
ou la créativité. Bien mémoriser, avec
beaucoup d’amorces, ça permet de sortir
les bonnes connaissances au bon moment, et
parfois d’une façon originale et créative.
Autre élément important sur le
fonctionnement de la mémoire à
long-terme : elle ne stocke pas que
des connaissances factuelles, brutes,
comme une date ou une formule. Elle permet aussi
de stocker des connaissances conceptuelles,
de la compréhension, sous la forme de
ce qu’on appelle des schémas mentaux.
Un schéma mental c’est un ensemble de concepts
dont on comprend les liens et les articulations,
et qui forment un tout cohérent, qu’on
peut utiliser pour faire des déductions,
des raisonnements. Et comme vous le savez sans
doute, quand on a vraiment compris quelque chose,
c’est toujours plus simple à récupérer, à
mobiliser, qu’une connaissance par coeur.
Que l’on parle d’une formule ou d’un
fait historique, il est toujours plus
simple de s’en souvenir avec précision si l’on a
compris le rôle qu’ils jouent dans le contexte,
s’ils font partie d’un schéma
mental cohérent plus global.
Bien, grâce à ce modèle sur la mémoire, on voit
bien ce qu’on veut essayer de faire avec nos
méthodes d’apprentissage : encoder efficacement,
favoriser la consolidation dans la mémoire à long
terme, mémoriser des connaissances conceptuelles
sous la forme de schémas mentaux, et améliorer
la récupération grâce à des amorces qui rendent
nos connaissances disponibles et mobilisables.
Mais avant d’aller plus loin et d’expliquer
comment on peut faire tout ça, je voudrais
tordre le cou à un des mythes les plus tenaces
qui existent en matière d’apprentissage : celui
des styles d’apprentissage. Vous savez «Ah
moi je suis plutôt un visuel», «ah non,
moi je suis plutôt auditif,
j’ai besoin d’entendre», etc.
Beaucoup de gens pensent avoir un style de
prédilection, qui leur permet d’apprendre
mieux. Eh bien c’est complètement
faux. C’est une idée qui a été balancé
par un type un jour, depuis
il y a eu littéralement des
dizaines d’études scientifiques sur
cette notion, et juste c’est faux.
Vous avez peut-être un style que vous préférez,
mais c’est juste une préférence personnelle,
ça n’est pas lié au fait d’apprendre mieux, à
l’efficacité de tel ou tel mode. Par contre ce
qui a été constaté, c’est qu’on apprend tous
mieux en utilisant plusieurs modes : visuel,
textuel, auditif, tactile. C’est ce qu’on
appelle la multimodalité, et on va en reparler.
Bien assez papoté, c’était important pour
moi de vous expliquer les fondements,
mais maintenant allons-y pour les
méthodes qui marchent vraiment.
[jingle]
Une chose qu’on entend souvent, c’est que la
répétition est à la base de la mémorisation.
Et c’est vrai, sauf cas particulier, vous
ne pouvez pas retenir quelque chose en le
voyant juste une fois et en pensant
à autre chose après. Il faut répéter,
pour exposer plusieurs fois notre
cerveau à l’information à mémoriser.
Mais il existe un principe fondamental, celui de
la répétition espacée. Pour le présenter,
on fait souvent une courbe de ce genre.
[OUBLI Vous venez d’apprendre quelque
chose pour la première fois, vous avez
réussi à le faire passer de votre mémoire
de travail à votre mémoire à long-terme.
Pas de difficulté à vous en rappeler quinze
minutes après, votre souvenir est à 100%.
Et puis le temps passe, et vous commencez à
oublier, assez vite. Passé quelques jours,
impossible de se souvenir, la
connaissance semble perdue.
Même si vous aviez passé plein de temps
dessus au début. Et ce qu’il faut faire,
c’est la réactiver avant d’avoir oublié,
disons le lendemain, de façon à interrompre
le processus d’oubli. Vous réapprenez à
nouveau, et vous voilà de retour à 100%.
Mais cette fois l’acte de réviser avant
l’oubli complet va aider à consolider,
à solidifier le souvenir dans
votre mémoire à long-terme.
Cela va légèrement renforcer le chemin
neuronal qui permet la récupération.
A partir de là, vous allez à nouveau commencer
à oublier progressivement, mais à un rythme plus
faible qu’avant. Sauf qu’au bout de quelques
jours, même principe : il faut réactiver
avant d’oublier, ce qui permet de revenir à
100%, mais aussi consolider encore un peu plus
le souvenir. Et à partir de là son érosion
sera encore plus lente. Et ainsi de suite.]
Ce que cela montre, c’est qu’il faut
distribuer votre apprentissage dans le temps,
il faut l’espacer, et en principe de plus en
plus. Ça ne sert à rien de s’acharner comme un
fou la première fois qu’on apprend, pour ensuite
ne rien faire pour entretenir la connaissance.
Contrairement à une croyance répandue,
si vous vous relisez un truc 100 fois
d’affilée la première fois, vous n’allez pas
du tout le «graver dans votre mémoire»,
il sera aussi vite oublié. Sauf si vous
le réactivez plusieurs fois ensuite,
en espaçant de plus en plus.
Et chaque réactivation sera
d’autant plus efficace que l’oubli aura
commencé, mais sans être allé au bout.
En pratique, cela veut dire que si on prend
un sujet donné que vous devez maitriser,
il vaut mieux travailler dessus 8 fois une heure,
en espaçant sur plusieurs jours, que
8h d’affilée condensé sur une journée.
Et c’est particulièrement important si vous
avez des examens en fin d’année ou de semestre.
Si vous bossez le sujet à fond en début
d’année, et que vous ne le réactivez pas
avant les révisions finales, vous n’allez pas
réviser, vous allez juste devoir tout réapprendre.
Idéalement il faut un peu entretenir
toute l’année. Bien sûr ça demande de la
discipline et de l’anticipation, mais c’est
pour éviter de gâcher vos efforts initiaux.
Évidemment la question que vous
allez vous poser, c’est : tout
les combien de temps doit-on réactiver
? Eh bien pour la première réactivation,
il faut la faire le lendemain. Ça aura laissé
le temps d’une première consolidation dans la
mémoire à long terme, dont on sait qu’elle
se produit en partie pendant le sommeil.
Pour la deuxième réactivation, deux ou
trois jours après. Puis la semaine suivante,
et après le mois suivant. L’idéal pour appliquer
cette méthode, c’est de se créer un calendrier
de réactivation pour être sur de ne pas laisser
reposer trop longtemps un truc qu’on a appris et
qui risque de se perdre. Il n’y a pas vraiment
de chiffre magique au bout duquel on aura la
certitude d’avoir acquis un savoir pour toujours,
mais disons que 7 est un bon ordre de grandeur.
Voilà donc, le premier principe,
c’est celui de la répétition espacée,
et donc de l’étalement de vos efforts
dans le temps. Voyons maintenant le
deuxième principe qui se combine très
bien avec celui-ci : celui de l’auto-test.
[OUBLI Revenons à ma courbe d’oubli :
au bout de 24h, j’ai commencé à oublier,
il est temps de réactiver. Mais comment
on réactive, concrètement ? Une façon
simple et confortable, c’est de relire
l’information à mémoriser. Par exemple
on relit son cours le lendemain,
comme si on l’apprenait à nouveau.
Sur mon schéma cognitif, ça correspond
à répéter la procédure d’encodage. On
refait passer à nouveau le souvenir de
la mémoire de travail vers la mémoire à
long-terme. Et effectivement, la réactivation
par ré-encodage, ça fonctionne un peu,
il y a un léger effet de renforcement et de
consolidation dans la mémoire à long-terme.]
Le problème est que, souvent, quand on fait
ça, on est pas forcément très concentré. En
relisant juste des choses qu’on a déjà
apprises, on se dit assez facilement
«ouais bon c’est bon, je le
savais». La réactivation est passive,
et on s’illusionne un peu sur ce
dont on se souvenait vraiment.
Et ce qui est bien plus efficace, c’est de
réactiver dans l’autre sens, par la récupération.
C’est-à-dire en essayant de se souvenir, de sortir
les connaissances de notre mémoire à long terme.
Généralement, ce travail de récupération, on
a tendance à le faire seulement quand on en
a besoin, c’est-à-dire le jour de l’examen.
Alors qu’il faudrait le faire pour réviser,
c’est-à-dire prendre l’habitude de
s’auto-tester, avant de vérifier les réponses.
Si vous devez réviser des dates
par exemple, plutôt que de relire
passivement le cours qui les contient,
essayez de répondre à des questions qui
vous demandent de vous en souvenir. C’est
un peu plus fatigant, je vous l’accorde,
mais cet effort va justement renforcer les
chemins neuronaux et les amorces de récupération,
et donc améliorer la durabilité et la
disponibilité de cette connaissance.
[OUBLI Et toutes les études montrent de façon très
claire, que cette récupération active est beaucoup
plus efficace que la relecture, qui fonctionne
de façon passive. Sur ma courbe d’oubli,
en réactivant de façon active, par
récupération, vous allez obtenir une
érosion ensuite bien moindre que si vous aviez
simplement relu et réencodé l’information.]
Et donc l’idéal, c’est de combiner les
deux premières méthodes qu’on vient de
voir : la récupération active par auto-test,
mais de façon espacée. Pour ça une technique
simple et puissante, c’est la boite de Leitner.
Leitner c’est un journaliste scientifique
allemand qui a imaginé cette méthode dans
les années 70. Pour la pratiquer, il vous
faudra une boite avec 7 compartiments,
vous pouvez prendre 7 enveloppes
aussi, et des petites fiches bristol.
Quand vous voulez apprendre quelque chose
de nouveau, une définition, une formule,
une date, un fait, vous le notez sous la
forme d’une question au recto d’une fiche,
et vous notez la réponse attendue au verso. Et
vous mettez la fiche dans le premier compartiment.
A partir de là, vous allez chaque jour
consulter les différents compartiments
et essayer de répondre aux questions
inscrites sur les fiches. Quand vous
répondez juste, vous placez la fiche dans le
compartiment suivant. Et si vous avez faux,
vous la remettez dans le premier compartiment.
Et pour assurer qu’il y ait le bon espacement au
fur et à mesure de l’apprentissage, vous n’allez
pas consulter tous les compartiments à chaque
fois. Le premier ce sera tous les jours, le second
seulement tous les deux jours, le troisième
peut-être tous les 4 jours, etc. Pour aider,
on peut utiliser un petit calendrier qui vous dit
chaque jour quels sont les compartiments à vider.
Avec cette méthode, quand vous répondez juste
à une question qui est dans le 7e compartiment,
ça veut dire que vous avez réussi 7 fois de suite,
et de façon de plus en plus espacée, donc
vous pouvez considérer que c’est bon !
Moi je me suis fait un petit système avec
une boite plastique et des fiches cartonnées,
mais si vous le voulez, il y a aussi
des applis mobiles qui font ça,
par exemple Anki, que je n’ai pas vraiment
testé mais qui semble assez populaire.
Un des avantages de cette méthode, c’est que
vous avez un retour immédiat sur ce que vous
savez. Et vous retravaillez automatiquement tous
les trucs sur lesquels vous n’êtes pas à l’aise,
puisqu’ils reviennent dans
le premier compartiment. Ça
évite de se bercer d’illusions
sur ce que l’on sait vraiment.
Evidemment, cela demande de la discipline
et des efforts, mais malheureusement,
les méthodes efficaces, reposantes
et faciles, ça n’existe pas !
Au-delà de la méthode de Leitner, de façon
générale, toutes les méthodes qui permettent
de se tester sont bonnes pour consolider la
mémoire au moyen d’une récupération. Donc cela
peut être aussi des questions ou des QCM dans les
manuels scolaires, sur des sites internets dédiés.
Et si vos enseignants vous en donnent
à faire, tant mieux. Souvenez-vous que
l’objectif premier de ces petits tests, ça
n’est pas de vous noter ou de vous évaluer,
le fait de se tester est une partie
intégrante du processus d’apprentissage
et de mémorisation. Avec les auto-tests, ça n’est
pas le résultat qui compte, c’est le chemin !
Un autre principe qui fonctionne très bien, et
qui se combine bien avec les deux précédents,
c’est celui de la diversification. Ça a
surtout été démontré dans les disciplines
plutôt scientifiques : l’idée est que si vous avez
plusieurs chapitres un peu différents à réviser,
il vaut mieux les mélanger en petites sessions,
que de faire tout l’un, puis tout l’autre.
En effet un des défis quand on a des problèmes
à résoudre, notamment en sciences, c’est
d’identifier correctement le type de problème,
et la bonne méthode à mobiliser pour le résoudre.
Le fait de mélanger les révisions sur plusieurs
chapitres proches va augmenter votre capacité
à bien discriminer les problèmes, mieux
voir les similarités et les différences,
et donc choisir les bonnes méthodes.
En mélangeant, on crée plus d’amorces
de récupération et on facilite le fait de
mobiliser les bonnes connaissances au bon moment.
Bien cela, fait trois principes : répétition
espacée, auto-tests et diversification. Jusqu’ici,
j’ai beaucoup parlé de mémoire, et vous vous
dites peut-être que dans votre domaine d’étude,
ça n’est pas ce qui est le plus important. Mais
on va voir maintenant comment transférer tous
ces bénéfices aussi pour la compréhension
conceptuelle et la résolution de problèmes.
[jingle]
Quand je vous ai parlé des auto-tests tout à
l’heure, j’ai évoqué par exemple le fait de
faire des petits QCM. Le QCM c’est bien, mais
comme on choisit dans une liste toute faite,
c’est moins efficace que d’essayer de trouver
et formuler soi-même la réponse à la question.
Et même pour aller encore plus loin,
plutôt que de répondre à des questions,
on peut essayer de se tester simplement
en essayant d’écrire tout ce dont on se
souvient. C’est ce qu’on appelle le rappel libre,
et cela fonctionne particulièrement bien car cela
vous oblige souvent à reformuler
les choses avec vos propres mots.
Et ça fait partie d’un groupe de méthodes
qu’on appelle l’apprentissage génératif,
ou l’apprentissage constructif. L’idée
générale, c’est que pour vous approprier
véritablement quelque chose, il va falloir
y mettre du vôtre, pour l’interpréter,
le réorganiser, le structurer d’une façon
qui lui donne du sens, et qui vous parle.
Pour votre cerveau, ça veut dire
fabriquer lui-même, de façon active,
ces petits schémas mentaux dont j’ai parlé, qui
viennent structurer les connaissances dans la
mémoire à long terme, et qui sont beaucoup
plus simples à retenir et à mobiliser.
C’est cette démarche active de construction de
schémas mentaux qui va vous permettre d’acquérir
des connaissances profondes, conceptuelles et
interconnectées. Le côté actif est très important,
car sinon c’estfacile de se donner l’impression
de bosser en se mettant en pilote automatique.
Vous savez : on relit plein de fois le
même passage, mais sans vraiment y être.
Ou bien en cours, on note par réflexe ce que le
prof raconte, mais nos pensées sont complètement
ailleurs. Comme si les mots allaient de l’oreille
au stylo sans vraiment passer par le cerveau.
Pour éviter ça, il faut se mettre dans une
posture active vis-à-vis du contenu qu’on
essaye d’assimiler. Il faut réfléchir dessus,
pour se l’approprier. Évidemment ça demande
plus d’efforts, mais ça permet aussi d’activer des
tâches cognitives supérieures qui vont améliorer
notre compréhension, notre mémoire à long-terme
et nos capacités à mobiliser les connaissances.
Je pense que vous le savez, on retient bien mieux
ce que l’on comprend et qui a du sens pour nous.
Petite démonstration : voici quelques suites de
lettres, essayez de les retenir. Hop terminé,
pas facile hein. Maintenant voici d’autres
suites de lettres. Ah, tout de suite c’est
beaucoup plus facile ! Il y a autant de
lettres qu’avant, mais ici elles forment
un motif qui a du sens, qu’on arrive à
relier à des connaissances antérieures.
C’est le cas dans toutes les disciplines
scolaires, prenez l’histoire par exemple.
Il est bien plus facile de retenir des
faits historiques si on comprend comment
ils s’enchaînent, leurs conséquences,
leurs relations à d’autres événements,
ou au monde actuel. Et pareil
en biologie ou en philosophie.
Pour faire ça, et aborder l’apprentissage
de façon active, il faut faire l’effort
de réfléchir soi-même à quels sont les
concepts-clés, quel sens on peut leur donner,
comment on peut les organiser et les
connecter à ce que l’on sait déjà.
C’est ce travail qui va vous permettre de créer
vos propres schémas mentaux, plus facile à stocker
dans la mémoire à long terme. Et plus on va
progresser et apprendre des choses nouvelles,
plus on sera à même de faire des liens, et
donc de créer des amorces de récupération.
Alors toutes ces recommandations sont
assez théoriques, voyons comment on
peut faire en pratique. Il existe
plein de façons complémentaires,
mais elles ont toutes une chose en commun : elles
demandent de la motivation et de la discipline.
Pour commencer, quand vous êtes en cours,
prenez des notes actives. Un bon moyen est
d’utiliser la marge, elle est là pour ça.
Notez-y des questions qui vous viennent,
des concepts qui vous semblent importants,
des exemples supplémentaires que vous trouvez,
des liens que ça vous évoque avec d’autres
notions ou des situations réelles.
N’ayez pas peur de spéculer ou de vous
tromper, écrivez au crayon de papier,
on s’en fiche, vous corrigerez plus tard,
l’important est de maintenir votre cerveau
dans une posture active qui va le préparer
à mieux apprendre tout ça par la suite.
Après la classe, faites du rappel
libre. Prenez une feuille blanche,
et écrivez tout ce dont vous vous
souvenez. Mais vraiment tout,
et ne vous arrêtez pas avant d’être vraiment à
sec. Forcez-vous à y passer un certain temps,
disons 5 ou 10 minutes. Plus vous irez chercher
loin dans votre mémoire, plus l’ancrage sera fort.
Idéalement, il faudrait le faire
le soir même après le cours,
pas la veille du prochain cours. Oui
ça demande de la discipline mais l’idée
est d’assurer un ancrage initial,
avant la première nuit de sommeil.
Ensuite quand vous travaillez votre cours,
essayez de reformuler les choses à votre sauce,
avec vos propres mots. Juste surligner
le cours, ça ne sert pas à grand chose,
ça demande trop peu d’efforts. Et pareil,
faire des fiches, si c’est juste pour
recopier exactement la même chose en plus
petit, plus serré et avec des abréviations,
c’est très pauvre. C’est quasiment faisable
en pilote automatique, sans réfléchir.
Pour travailler son cours de façon active, je
connais un prof d’histoire géo qui au collège
faisait faire à ses élèves un truc très
simple : il leur demandait systématiquement
pour le prochain cours de préparer 5 questions
portant sur la leçon qu’ils venaient de faire.
Cela forçait les élèves à réfléchir au
cours, à sélectionner ce qui était important,
à imaginer des questions avec leurs propres mots,
et les réponses qui allaient avec. Et
en plus si vous adoptez cette technique,
ça vous créera des questions qui seront
utilisables pour faire des auto-tests.
Dans le même genre, mon prof en maths sup nous
avait expliqué comment travailler son cours de
façon active, en essayant de l’enrichir,
en se posant des questions. Pourquoi on
a choisi cette définition, et pas une autre.
Est-ce qu’il existe plusieurs démonstrations
à ce théorème. Quels contre-exemples je
trouve si j’enlève une hypothèse, etc.
Une méthode très efficace de reformulation,
qui marche pour toutes les matières,
c’est la schématisation. Essayez de créer vos
propres petits diagrammes pour représenter les
concepts clés, et comment ils sont reliés entre
eux. Cela permet de combiner le textuel et le
visuel. On l’a dit, c’est la multiplication
des modes d’apprentissage qui est importante.
Pour le faire encore mieux, il y a une méthode
que j’adore, que j’utilise énormément, c’est la
technique de la carte mentale. C’est une méthode
d’organisation des idées qui consiste à essayer de
résumer les choses sur une seule feuille, en
utilisant une structure en arbre. Le concept
principal au centre, puis des branches successives
pour exprimer les idées, les sous-idées etc.
Dans une carte mentale, on essaye
de mettre en avant des liens,
des regroupements ou des différences. On
utilise au maximum des petits dessins,
et de la couleur, à nouveau pour stimuler
à la fois le textuel et le visuel. Et aussi
il faut la créer à la main, pour avoir
aussi le côté tactile ou kinesthésique.
La méthode de la carte mentale coche beaucoup
de principes efficaces d’apprentissage,
et je la trouve fantastique
quand on doit s’approprier
un cours de façon active, en le questionnant
et en le reformulant à sa façon.
Et ça n’est pas juste mon opinion personnelle
: il existe de nombreuses études qui montrent
que les méthodes comme la carte mentale, qui
combinent schématisation visuelle et relations
entre concepts, ont un effet redoutable
sur la mémoire et la compréhension.
Je vous encourage vraiment à étudier cette
technique, avec toutefois une petite mise en
garde. Il faut prendre un peu de temps pour se
former et se l’approprier vraiment. Il ne faut
pas que la mise en oeuvre de la méthode vous
soit fastidieuse, ou vous bloque par crainte
de mal s’y prendre. Je ferai peut-être
une vidéo dédiée sur le sujet un jour.
Passons à une dernière façon bien connue de faire
de l’apprentissage génératif : essayer d’expliquer
à d’autres le contenu qu’on s’efforce d’apprendre
et de comprendre. C’est vraiment quelque chose
que j’ai vécu des tas de fois en préparant
mes vidéos : quand on essaye de transmettre
quelque chose de façon claire, on se rend très
vite compte si on n’a pas vraiment compris.
C’est un peu le révélateur ultime qui montre la
différence entre maîtriser superficiellement,
connaître les trucs par cœur, savoir
utiliser bêtement les formules,
et la vraie compréhension conceptuelle.
L’idéal pour ça, c’est de travailler à
plusieurs et de jouer alternativement
le rôle de celui qui explique et de celui
qui écoute. Mais pour commencer simple,
vous pouvez essayer de le faire sur vous-même.
Imaginez expliquer ce que vous avez appris à
votre moi du passé. Une autre façon de faire
popularisée par le physicien Richard Feynman,
c’est d’essayer de faire semblant
de l’expliquer à un enfant de 8 ans.
Voilà, ça fait beaucoup d’infos, il
est temps de conclure et de faire
une petite synthèse de ce qu’on a vu aujourd’hui.
[jingle]
Premier point : il existe vraiment des méthodes
plus efficaces que d’autres, abondamment testées
et validées par des études scientifiques,
donc utilisez les. Car vos capacités ne
sont pas figées, vous avez bien plus la main
que vous ne l’imaginez sur vos apprentissages.
Par contre, je ne dis pas que ça va être facile ou
reposant. Ces méthodes demandent de la régularité,
de la motivation et une forme de discipline. Et
je l’ai dit plusieurs fois, elles ne sont pas
confortables, elles demandent de l’effort, mais
c’est aussi pour ça qu’elles fonctionnent. Mais au
moins on ne se berce pas d’illusions avec
des méthodes rassurantes mais inefficaces.
De façon générale, une qualité très importante
à développer, c’est votre capacité à prendre du
recul sur la façon dont vous apprenez,
dont vous approchez les problèmes,
dont vous jugez de ce qui marche ou ne marche
pas dans tel ou tel contexte. C’est ce qu’on
appelle parfois la métacognition, la capacité
à réfléchir sur vos propres modes de pensées.
Je vous ai présenté beaucoup de techniques
aujourd’hui, et il n’y en a pas une qui est
supérieure aux autres. Il faut choisir
et combiner en essayant de respecter les
principes généraux que sont l’espacement,
l’auto-test et l’apprentissage génératif.
Moi perso si je retournais au collège,
au lycée ou en études supérieures,
je ferais au moins boîte de Leitner
et cartes mentales, avec peut-être un
peu de rappel libre le soir des cours, et de la
création de questions pour ma boite de Leitner.
Évidemment, je l’ai dit, tout ça est
à adapter en fonction de la matière,
de votre niveau d’études, et toutes
les techniques ne seront pas utiles de
la même façon. Dans tous les cas je vous
mets plein de références en description,
des articles scientifiques, des livres, blogs
et personnes qui m’ont inspiré. Et notamment
un grand merci à Elena Pasquinelli, qui m’a
fourni pas mal de références sur ces sujets.?
Voilà c’est tout pour aujourd’hui,
rendez vous sur le discord de Science
Étonnante pour prolonger la discussion.
Abonnez vous si ça n’est pas déjà le cas,
et on se retrouve très vite pour
une nouvelle vidéo, à bientôt !